>> THE KIDS CASH IN.
THAT'S THE ANGLE.
THE BRITISH ROYALTY HAS BEEN
COCAINE TO THE PRESS.
THEY CAN NEVER GET ENOUGH OF IT.
IN THE TABLOID ERA, PRINCESS
DIANA, THEN WILLIAM AND KATE.
BUT THERE'S A WHOLE NEW LEVEL OF
ADD RATION FOR PRINCE HARRY AND
HIS WIFE, MEGHAN MARKEL.
FOR THE GLOBAL ELITES, THE DUKE
AND DUCHESS OF SUSSEX WERE A
LONG-AWAITED CURE-ALL FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WAS WRONG IN THE
STUFFY STUCK UP PROTOCOL OF THE
ROYAL FAMILY.
>> I APPRECIATE OUR PLANET AND
WHAT IT HAS TO OFFER.
THE WORLD WE LIVE IN CAN'T BE
REPLICATED OR TAMED.
>> FEMINISM IS ABOUT FAIRNESS.
THE BASIC AND FUNDAMENTAL HUMAN
RIGHT OF BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CHOICES FOR
YOUR FUTURE AND THAT OF YOUR
COMMUNITY.
>> IT'S A BIRACIAL WOMAN
MARRYING INTO AN INSTITUTION
SEEN BY SO MANY AS A BASTION OF
WHITE PRIVILEGE AND A SYMBOL OF
THE ABUSES OF COLONIALISM,
MEGHAN MARKEL HAS QUICKLY BEEN
ADOPTED AS A BEACON OF POTENTIAL
CHANGE HERE.
>> WELL, AFTER MONTHS OF
COMPLAINING THAT THEY ACTUALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN ACCEPTED BY THE
ROYALS, HARRY AND MEGHAN DROPPED
A BOMBSHELL, DIDN'T CALL THE
QUEEN, BUT THEY DID IT VIA
INSTAGRAM INSISTING THAT WE
INTEND TO STEP BACK AS SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE ROYAL FAMILY AND
WORK TO BECOME FINANCIALLY
INDEPENDENT WHILE CONTINUING TO
SUPPORT HER MAJESTY, THE QUEEN.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE'RE NOT GOING
TO DO WHAT'S EXPECTED OF US.
BUT WE'RE HAPPY TO CASH IN ON
THE WHOLE ROYAL THING.
>> THEY WANT TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE QUEEN AND PRINCE CHARLES AND
PRINCE WILLIAM RATHER THAN
HAVING A SYSTEM WHERE THEY HAVE
TO BE TOLD WHAT TO DO ALL THE
TIME.
>> SOUNDS LIKE MY KIDS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO.
THEY JUST WANT TO KEEP
GETTING -- ALL RIGHT.
THEY HAD THE BENEFITS OF BEING A
PRINCE AND A PRINCESS.
THEY SEE THEMSELVES MORE LIKE
JAY-Z AND BEYONCE THAN WILL AND
KATE OR DUKE AND DUCHESS.
THERE ARE REPORTS THEY EVEN
TRADEMARKED THEIR TITLES OR WANT
TO AS THEY WAIT FOR WHAT, I
DON'T KNOW, THEIR BABY BOY TO
DETERMINE THEIR OWN GENDER
IDENTITY.
A TRANSCONTINENTAL LIFE LIKELY
IN CANADA AND IN ENGLAND.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, THEY'LL STILL
LIVE OFF OF THE ROYAL FAMILY.
AND IN THE UK, THEY'LL CONTINUE
TO RESIDE AT THE PALATIAL HOME
GIFTED TO THEM BY THE QUEEN AND
REFURBISHED FOR THEM COURTESY OF
THE BRITISH TAXPAYERS.
THE ROYAL FAMILY STILL REELING
WITH PRINCE ANDREW'S CONNECTION
WITH JEFFREY EPSTEIN IS
REPORTEDLY APPALLED BY THE DUO'S
UNGRATEFUL, BOORISH BEHAVIOR.
DON'T WORRY.
HARRY AND MEGHAN ARE STARTING A
CHARITABLE FOUNDATION TO HELP
YOU LITTLE PEOPLE.
WE IN THE U.S. HAVE OUR OWN
ROYAL WANNABES, THOUGH, DON'T
WE?
THEY ALSO ENJOY EXPLOITING THE
FORMER POSITION FOR PILES OF
CASH.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE CLINTONS.
THEY ENTERED THE WHITE HOUSE IN
'92 WORTH NOTHING.
BUT THE TIME THEY GOT SETTLED TO
PRIVATE LIFE, BILL CLINTON WAS
WORTH $240 MILLION.
DID THAT MANY PEOPLE REALLY BUY
THEIR LOUSY MEMOIRS.
THAT'S ON TOP OF WHAT THEY
RAISED FOR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION WHICH TOOK IN $249
MILLION IN HILLARY CLINTON'S
FIRST YEAR AS SECRETARY OF
STATE.
HMM.
THEY CONVENIENTLY THEN GRAFTED
THEIR DAUGHTER, CHELSEA INTO THE
SCAM BY NAMING HER VICE CHAIR OF
THE FOUNDATION.
>> WE ARE PROBABLY MOST WELL
KNOWN FOR OUR WORK IN HEALTH.
WE ALSO WORK IN CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WE WORK ON EMPOWERING WOMEN
AND GIRLS AROUND THE WORLD,
SUPPORTING WOMEN ENTREPRENEURS
AROUND THE WORLD, FROM HAITI TO
WEST AFRICA TO INDIA.
>> YEAH.
IT'S ALL ABOUT HAITI.
WELL, CHELSEA IS A WOMAN BEST
KNOWN FOR HER LAST NAME WITH NO
DISCERNIBLE PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE.
I'M SURE SHE'S A NICE PERSON.
BUT SHE MADE $9 MILLION SINCE
2011 BY SITTING ON THE BOARD OF
AN INTERNET INVESTMENT FIRM RUN
BY HER MOM'S FRIEND.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL.
FOR HER NONEXISTENT EXPERIENCE
IN BROADCAST JOURNALISM, SHE WAS
ALSO PAID $26,724 PER MINUTE AS
A SPECIAL CORRESPONDENT FOR NBC.
AGAIN, DESPITE HAVING ZERO
BROADCAST EXPERIENCE OR MEDIA
TALENT.
NOW, SHE'S A BEST-SELLING
CHILDREN'S AUTHOR, OCCASIONALLY
SHARING WRITING CREDITS WITH
THAT OTHER BELOVED CHILDREN'S
SCRIBE, HER MOTHER, HILLARY
CLINTON.
>> I WILL SAY, I DO TALK TO MY
MOTHER MORE NOW THAN I HAVE MADE
HER A GRANDMOTHER.
I HAVE --
>> DEFINITELY WORTH MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THAT DOG AND PONY
SHOW.
WELL, LOOK, IT'S A ROUTINE
COPIED BY FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
JOE BIDEN'S FAVORITE SON,
HUNTER.
MIDDLE CLASS JOE WENT FROM
HAVING POSSIBLY NEGATIVE NET
WORTH TURNING MORE THAN $15
MILLION SINCE LEAVING OFFICE,
AND HIS SON SEEMS TO HAVE
LEARNED THE SECRET OF SUCCESS,
NEPOTISM.
HUNTER BIDEN RANKED IN $50,000 A
MONTH AS A MEMBER OF THE
UKRAINIAN GAS COMPANY, BARISMA
DESPITE HAVING NO ENERGY
EXPERIENCE AT ALL.
AND WE DON'T KNOW HOW HUNTER
BENEFITTED FROM THE BUSINESS
DEALS IN CHINA, HOW MUCH HE
BENEFITTED.
BUT ACCORDING TO THE
BIDEN-LOVING MEDIA, IT'S THE
TRUMP CHILDREN WHO ARE THE REAL
PROBLEM.
>> IT'S THE TRUMP KIDS ALMOST
EVERY DAY THEY PROBABLY MAKE
MORE MONEY THAN HUNTER BIDEN
MADE IN ALL OF HIS YEARS IN
SERVING INVESTORS AND PUBLIC --
IN COMPANIES ABROAD.
>> CERTAINLY HUNTER BIDEN WAS
NOT THE FIRST ONE.
YOU LOOK AT THE -- THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF THE TRUMP KIDS.
>> PROBABLY THE MOST UNETHICAL
GROUP OF PEOPLE WE'VE EVER SEEN
IN THIS REPUBLIC.
>> LAURA: OKAY, I CAN'T FINISH
THE MONOLOGUE TONIGHT.
HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THE TRUMP KIDS DIDN'T GET RICH
OFF OF BEING IN PUBLIC OFFICE.
THEY ACTUALLY HAD MADE THEIR
MONEY BEFORE THEIR -- BEFORE THE
PRESIDENT WAS ELECTED.
IT CAME FROM RUNNING SOMETHING
CALLED A BUSINESS -- OKAY?
MAKING A PAYROLL.
IN FACT, THE PRESIDENT -- BY
SOME ACCOUNTS, HAVE LOST MONEY
SINCE TAKING OFFICE, MAYBE AS
MUCH AS A $1 BILLION, THE
BUSINESSES WHICH HIS KIDS RUN
ARE SUFFERING, SOME OF THE
PROPERTIES AND RESORTS ARE
REPORTEDLY LOSING SOME MONEY.
BUT THE MEDIA TELLS US IT'S THE
TRUMP KIDS THAT NEED TO BE WATCH
AND HELD IN SUSPICION.
THAT'S KIND OF A NIFTY TRICK,
ISN'T IT?
I GUESS THE TRUMP KIDS NEED TO
GO BANKRUPT IN ORDER TO PASS THE
ETHICS TEST TO THE LEFT.
MEANWHILE, LIBERALS WITH FAMILY
CONNECTIONS AND COOL
HUMANITARIAN IDEAS, BUT ZERO